four hours they waited on some peter's
square at exactly noon Pope Francis
appeared on the balcony of st. Peter's
Basilica faithful from all over the
world gave him a roaring welcome
thousands have come to Rome many from
his native argentina in his Christmas
address he repeated his message of
concern for the world's poor and weak as
he celebrated the birth of Christ he
expressed his wish for joy and peace
Betty Jo by Neil if I meet for the
children and the old people young people
and families for the poor and
marginalized na da ba Noi hope Francis
called for an end to the wars in Syria
in South Sudan and the Central African
Republic continuum our pragati let us
continue to ask the Lord to spare the
beloved Syrian people further suffering
Norris offer NC and to enable the
parties in conflict to put an end to all
violence and guarantee access to
humanitarian aid you might need ID if
the Pope's message was unmistakable and
the crowd gave him a warm reception the
high point was the papal blessing Bobby
at or be parties its feel its p to
santee they send a super was it mine yet
sent Bethenny Frances blessed people
including those watching on TV as
remission of their punishment for sin
and the new pope has clearly won over
the crowd onsen peter's square I think
he's more with the people and likes to
talk to everybody and that's a good
thing mister soubise godless his
humility brings him closer he makes you
feel he's one of us laporta s true no
Dino
in his first Christmas message Pope
Francis has made it clear he sees
himself as an advocate of the poor and
the marginalized